Traductor: Andy Anderson
Revisor: Judit Rodríguez
(Música)
(Fin de la música)
(Aplausos)
Me gustaría invitarlos a que vayamos
un poquito atrás en el tiempo
a un viernes como hoy,
pero en mi adolescencia
o sea, casi la prehistoria.
(Risas)
Y ese viernes yo estaba
invitado a una fiesta
y como era un romántico empedernido
y lo sigo siendo
estaba convencido que ese viernes
iba a conocer a la mujer de mi vida,
y para eso, decidí recurrir
a mi arma de seducción más infalible:
una camisa estampada con flores.
(Risas)
No me pregunten por qué es el día de hoy
que no entiendo cómo todos mi amigos y yo
en la adolescencia teníamos, cada uno,
una camisa estampada con flores
como si el solo uso de la prenda
ya lograra que la mujeres cayeran
rendidas a nuestros pies,
cosa que no sucedió.
Pero además de la camisa de flores
yo quería saber cómo estaba, cómo me veía
y para eso, decidí pasearme
delante de mi madre
a ver qué me decía.
Pasé una vez: nada.
Segunda vez: nada.
Tercera vez, la encaré.
"Mamá, ¿te acordás
que hoy tengo esa fiesta
de la que tanto te hablé?"
"¿Cómo me veo?"
Y mamá, con absoluta poesía
me miró de arriba abajo
y de abajo hacia arriba
y me dijo:
"¿Así vas a ir a bailar?"
(Risas)
"¡No seas pajarón!"
"¿Quién va a querer bailar
con un florero en dos patas?"
Durante toda su vida
mamá criticó todo lo que yo hacía,
decía o pensaba.
Los amigos que elegía estaban mal,
los lugares que frecuentaba estaban mal
los libros que leía estaban mal,
la película que elegía ir a ver al cine
estaba mal,
mi perfume estaba mal,
mi equipo estaba mal,
todo lo que yo hacía estaba mal.
Mi nombre es Andy,
soy el segundo de cuatro hermanos,
y no me puedo quejar
porque mis padres me dieron todo:
seguridad, educación...
Mamá, en términos de crítica
no se guardó nada.
Y la verdad es que, de los cuatro hijos,
yo era el que más la resistía
no podía tolerar
tanto pensamiento negativo
entonces, la enfrentaba todo el tiempo.
Por eso siempre digo que con mamá
tuve una relación de alto impacto:
(Risas)
chocábamos todo el tiempo.
Hace seis años,
tras la muerte de mi padre,
mi madre cayó
en un cuadro severo de depresión
que derivó en Alzheimer,
la enfermedad que afecta
a 40 millones de personas
en todo el mundo.
Se estima que para el año 2050,
esta suma llegará
a los 150 millones de personas,
y las probabilidades
de padecer esta enfermedad,
en mayores de 85 años,
será de una cada dos personas.
La medicina descubrió el Alzheimer
hace más de cien años,
y a pesar de todos los progresos
y la evolución que tuvo en montón
de áreas y de patologías,
todavía no encontró una cura,
una respuesta o una solución.
El Alzheimer no perdona.
Y esto lo sé bien,
porque mi abuela falleció a los 78 años
con un cuadro de Alzheimer,
mi suegro hace más de 12 años
que tiene la enfermedad
y mamá está internada con Alzheimer
en un instituto y yo la voy a visitar
todas las semanas.
Ironías de la vida:
de sus cuatro hijos, el menor falleció,
y mi hermano mayor y mi hermana menor
emigraron a Estados Unidos,
así que soy el único en Argentina para
acompañarla durante este proceso.
El Alzheimer arrebata
de nuestros seres queridos
sus recuerdos y su memoria
que son fundamentales para toda persona.
Es lo que determina
nuestro lugar en el Universo,
nuestra relación con el tiempo
y el espacio.
Es lo que nos separa
de un ser vegetal o animal.
Y además, la enfermedad
que no perdona,
aniquila todas las estructuras temporales.
¿Qué significa esto?
Cuando voy a visitar a mamá,
ella no sabe si es viernes, sábado, lunes,
primavera o verano.
Por eso nos concentramos
en las cosas simples:
la altura de un árbol,
el color del otoño.
Yo, a veces, hasta me atrevo a repetir
un diálogo imaginario entre dos pajaritos
que se acercan a comer unas migajas de pan
y es todo muy divertido
lo pasamos muy bien
y a mí me demanda
un ejercicio creativo constante,
que me encanta,
hasta que mamá, en un rapto de lucidez
o quizás con un poco de nostalgia
por las "buenas, viejas épocas",
me mira, muy seria,
y me dice:
"¿vos creés que dos pajaritos
pueden hablar?"
"¡No seas pajarón!"
(Risas)
Sin embargo,
qué maravilla es poder vivir el instante.
Vivir el instante.
Cuántos poetas y escritores
han escrito páginas y páginas de libros
sobre la importancia
de atrapar el instante,
de vivir cada segundo,
cada momento de nuestras vidas.
A eso nos lleva
la enfermedad que no perdona.
Los pacientes de Alzheimer
se concentran en lo inmediato,
en lo simple.
Y yo, que sí sé lo que es planificar,
que sí sé lo que es una agenda
y que les podría decir
a todos los que están acá
exactamente cuántos días faltan
para la Navidad.
Con esta enfermedad
aprendí a valorar cada minuto
que estoy con mi madre a mi lado,
aunque ella, mentalmente,
esté en cualquier otra parte.
Hace poco ocurrió un pequeño milagro.
La fui a visitar, salimos a caminar,
me senté en un banco de plaza,
ella a mi lado,
y de la nada, empezó a hacerme caricias
en la espalda, con la palma abierta,
y como venimos de una familia que no está
habituada al contacto físico,
mi primer reacción fue:
"¿porqué estabas haciendo eso?"
Y mamá me dijo algo que nunca pensé
que iba a escuchar en mi vida.
Me miró con sus ojitos
y su voz un tanto ronca
y me dijo:
"Andy,
me encanta todo lo que hacés".
El Alzheimer nos desafía
a dar lo mejor que tenemos
los seres humanos,
que es el amor, absoluto e incondicional,
el amor que realmente lo da todo
y no espera nada a cambio.
Soy padre de dos hijas,
y recuerdo, hace mucho tiempo,
cuando les cambiaba los pañales:
la conexión que teníamos
a través de la mirada
era maravillosamente enigmática,
era maravillosamente enigmática.
Yo pensaba:
"estas pequeñas personas
no saben quién soy,
no saben quiénes son ellas,
en qué país viven
qué día es".
Y esto me hizo pensar:
igual que mamá con su cuadro de Alzheimer.
"yo también fui un bebé,
y mamá me alimentó,
me arropó, me cambió los pañales,
incluso se despertó
en el medio de la noche
para apaciguar mi llanto".
Y es con ese espíritu,
que yo llamo "el espíritu de los pañales",
que la voy a visitar.
Y cuando la traen hacia mí,
cuando la enfermera la acerca,
y ella está feliz, peinada,
a mí no me importa que no sepa qué día es,
que no sepa ni siquiera quién soy yo.
Porque como custodio de su memoria
yo sé quién es ella.
Como guardián de sus recuerdos,
yo no me olvido,
ni me pienso olvidar, de quién es ella.
El Alzheimer es implacable,
pero no es el fin del mundo.
Es apenas una etapa de la vida
como la primera infancia,
en la que nuestro ser querido
necesita de otro.
Todos los que estamos acá
fuimos bebés
y necesitamos de otro.
Esto se repite con el Alzheimer,
es una etapa de la vida.
No es el fin del mundo.
Y además es implacable y no tiene cura
y no tiene solución,
pero no puede con el amor.
Como conozco
muchos pacientes con Alzheimer
y cuando voy a visitar a mamá
saludo a Emma,
saludo a Santiago,
saludo a un montón de gente
y me doy cuenta que ellos perciben el amor
que uno les da.
En eso,
el Azlheimer no puede.
Para mí,
el Alzheimer es una oportunidad.
Una enfermedad que no tiene cura
me permitió curar mi relación con mamá.
Para mí, el Alzheimer es una bendición.
Por eso, les digo:
no esperemos a una enfermedad
que no perdona
para abrir el corazón y perdonar.
Hagámoslo a tiempo,
hagámoslo, sin enfermedades de por medio,
sin rencores,
sin culpas, a pleno, a fondo.
Hagámoslo ahora.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
(Música)